You are listening to radiolab radiolab
from [inaudible], w.
N. Y. S. E. N. N. P. R. Hey, I'm
Jad Abumrad. I'm Robert Krulwich,
Radiolab and today we have a story that
actually kind of seems to stick with
those who hear it. Can you hear us
now? Hello? Hello. Hello. Hello.
Like this Guy Walter Merge.
I'm a film editor and sound designer
and I've been working in film since the
late 1960s the resume includes, I'm
going to make them and off we go.
The Godfather apocalypse now.
I love the smell of that pump in
the morning. Ton of other films,
the thing we're talking about it,
so you should know is the one of the
more spectacular stories I've ever heard.
How did you bump into this tail?
Well, I was in Leon in
France doing a film,
unbearable lightness of being.
This is back in 1986 I was supposed to
be there for a week on it. Wound up,
I was there for a month and
I ran out of things to read.
So I went down the street from the
hotel and there was a bookstore and a,
I was interested and
still am in cosmology.
So I picked up a book by the,
uh, Carl Sagan of France,
a man named Hubert Reeves. [inaudible]
actually, he's French Canadian.
He translates this Gulf Sago. Anyway,
merchant ends up buying Reeves book,
goes back to the hotel, finds a cozy spot.
I was happily reading away and he was
trying to explain with some difficulty
because it was a difficult topic.
How did matter condense out of the sort
of cork soup that we believe happened
right after the big bang.
And He tried various,
uh, attempts scientifically, but
then he said, to give you a sense of,
uh, the poetry of this moment,
the best thing is the story
that Muller Parte tells.
[inaudible]
who is Mela party? Well,
he was a journalist, a
poet, a diplomat soldier,
prisoner film director
and somebody who, uh,
got around. Yeah. And speaking
of getting around in 1942,
a Melanie's newspaper
[inaudible] the loss,
Sarah sent Malaparte Day to report, um,
on the eastern and
northern fronts of the war.
Specifically the Russian Finnish border
and he had a front row seat of the siege
of Leningrad,
the agony of the Nazi bombardment
of that city and it's from there.
Then Malaparte he tells his story.
So this one day, this
was an in the winter,
Mala party was posted with the Finnish
army who were fighting along with the
Nazis and they were perched just north
of linen ground on the shores of Lake
Ladoga, which is this big lake
abutting the city and on this day
[inaudible],
the Nazis are bombarded
area around the lake.
This started a forest fire,
everyone ran for cover,
soldiers ran every which way.
In the middle of the forest there were
Soviet forces that were locked up in a
stable and
fortunately panicked and broke out of
the stable hundreds of them and they just
started running in Russian to get
away from the fighting. Right.
So you have hundreds of horses bolting
through this flaming forest heading
towards the open space I head,
which was the lake and all the ones
they burst out in the forest and go
barreling into the lake.
Stampeding one on top of the other is
y'all get deeper and deeper up to their
heads.
And it is this moment when they enter
the length that according to this story,
something very weird happens in
the blink of an eye, but like
snaps them shot, it just freezes,
suddenly turns to ice with a bang.
It goes from water to ice
with this violence snap and
suddenly the horses are in
two
mellow parte writes that even the waves
on the lake were gripped in midair and
sort of suspended there.
[inaudible]
the next morning when Mullah
party in the fins woke up,
they discovered the forest fire had
burned itself out. And look at that,
the lake has frozen solid overnight
and his finished friends said yes,
that sometimes happens and then they are
looking to see what are those bumps on
the ice over there.
They go to investigate and
I find themselves in this
horrific sculpture garden
of horses' heads sticking up out of
the solid marble like floor of ice,
like you said, hundreds. So hundreds
of course heads on roads, abortions,
these are the, these are not going to
decay, right? Cause it's freezing cold.
So they look there,
they s those horses stayed there all
winter and Muller Party was there in that
region of the world. Uh,
during that winter and every so often
he and the other soldiers would go and
have a smoke and they'd go into the
sculpture garden and wander around looking
up this miraculous thing.
So the [inaudible] of the
horses frozen in this lake,
there's image beautiful and
strange and disturbing and
the profound in some way made us
wonder, made me wonder. I should say,
I told you at the time,
it don't trust this story.
It's not scientifically impossible.
And I hold keeping an open heart.
You could this possibly be true.
Could, could there be a grain,
perhaps several grains, perhaps
eight lakes worth of grains of truth.
Your heart is story. Just your mind
is like loose, like a thick. Anyway,
I do
this for a year. Yeah. And
you know what? We're going to,
we're going to reconstruct that
argument right now and take this uptown.
All right. All right. Let's do this too.
A real scientist [inaudible] this.
In the course of our argument,
we ended up going uptown to Rockefeller
University to meet a couple people who
know about ice,
so we're going to go play with
some super cool of ice among them.
This fellow. Okay. I'm Alexandra Petroff.
I am the Raymond and
Beverly Sackler fellow.
Who did you ever wonder who are
Raymond and Beverly Sackler?
They occasionally almost show up and I
almost meet them, but I never have. Yeah.
In any case, Alex, who must
be said is an amazing dude,
graciously agreed to demonstrate that
you can in fact create the conditions of
that massive lake inside a
tiny little test tube. Okay.
Could somebody hold this road in
here and I'll get the tube set up?
Reached inside his freezer,
grabbed his trusty Falcon.
This is called a falcon tube. Just a
blessing too. Filled with water. No,
this is not normal water. This is
the really nice water. It's very,
very pure water. No minerals, no Dustin.
There's like super distilled and he says
when you take water like that and you
cool it down,
you can get it far below its freezing
point and it won't freeze unless that is,
you happen to have a horse.
You have a tiny horse here.
We have a tiny hole and we're going to
drop that into the Falcon Tube and do
that. That's going to be awesome.
So he handed us the tube.
I'm holding a little vile of
super cooled water. What else?
What temperature do you think this is
that am I gonna make money? This is mine.
Minus 20 c c Celsius. Wait,
when does water freezes at zero. So
it's 20 degrees below freezing point.
It's still water. But now for a long
cause we unscrewed the cap. Are you,
are you filming?
We held the little plastic horse over
the tube countdown or something. Okay.
On the count, three guilty.
All right. Three, two, one.
[inaudible]
for Jad because the moment that
little plastic course hit the water,
the water slammed into ice.
Suddenly that little guy was
trapped in an ice cube. Oh my God.
It's Thor's is frozen. That's amazing.
Please remember the horse was plastic.
No animals were harmed in this
experiment. Is this honestly breathtaking?
Like it happens so fast. Catastrophic
ice formation just like that.
Did you hear the c word? Robert?
Say it again. Catastrophic.
This is Virginia Walker and I'm in the
department of Biology Queens University.
Virginia was one of the many people that
we called up to ask like what the hell?
Like why does this happen? It shouldn't.
This water just freeze gradually the
way that most water does, you know,
at 32 degrees Fahrenheit or
whatever. No, actually, so you see,
this is why we have to start at the
beginning. As Julie Andrews said,
a very good to start. Right? Alright.
So the only reason that water freezes
normally at zero Celsius and 32 Fahrenheit
is that the something there that makes
it freeze, we call that a nuclear later.
Sounds like a superhero. Yeah. All
right, so it's a nuclear later.
A nuclear is like a seed, right?
Didn't know this but it turns out water
almost always needs a seed in order to
grow ice because it turns out water
by itself is not actually that good at
remembering how to become
ice. That is Erin pedit.
She's a glaciologist at the University
of Alaska Fairbanks and what she means is
that when water cools down, the
molecules start to slow their movement.
They get a little bit closer together and
at that point they want all hold hands
and become ice.
The water molecules don't quite remember
very well how they're supposed to be
organized. They're like, wait, do
you stand here a nice day in here?
How do we do this? Again,
they need to be shown what combination
of angles work the best to create a nice
stable structure. What they
need is say a speck of dust.
That's the nuclear. If you throw in
some dust into otherwise pure water,
now they have a guide because ice
can start to mimic whatever the, the,
the shape of the dust particle is who
had happens is that the water molecules
start to form a cage
around the dust particle.
And that cage shape is very similar
to the shape they need to make ice.
And suddenly they're like,
oh, that's how we do it.
So in a sense the dust
particle is reminding the
water molecules how to freeze.
Well, no, I don't think of it like that.
Virginia says it's actually
a not quite so gentle.
Really what's happening is
the dust particle is forcing
the water molecules into
the rate shape around it. It's
like a, it's like a command.
It's nothing about memory. It's,
it's, it's a physical thing.
They just get jammed in it. Wow.
That's just like Julie Andrews,
like a Nazi [inaudible].
So then these, these,
these meetings you'll get.
So if as we just learned water needs
a catalyst to nucleate or in order to
freeze,
does it this at least raise
the possibility that that
Finnish Russian lake had
reached a super cooled state along
come these horses and they were the
nucleators maybe they had dust on
their hair or whatever, I don't know.
Whatever it was, it
started a chain reaction.
Ice Spread outward from these horses
shot across the entire lake and froze the
whole damn thing at once.
[inaudible]
if you'll excuse me for just a second,
because this is like a
tyrading like impulse. I have
[inaudible] now we can continue
close yours there. Alright,
we'll get to your skepticism in a moment,
but I want to talk a little bit more
about nucleators for a second because when
we were talking with Virginia, she
told us something kind of cool.
We asked her like, what else? Uh,
nucleates ice, like we learned about dust,
but what else can do it? Okay, so
the best nuclear later is ice itself.
She says,
if a little bit of snow falls into some
water or a little bit ice forms in the
water, organically, the water molecules
will rush around that and Bam,
if you don't have ice,
what is the second best thing to
nucleate this ice happens to be bacteria
today.
She says there are three different kinds
of bacteria that can generate these
special proteins, big honkin proteins
that can instantly turn water into ice.
In fact,
when we were reporting the story of
video started circulating on the Internet
that showed a scientist taken a
bottle of water squirting coat,
a little bit of this bacteria in, and
then the thing just shot in the ice.
And the cool thing is these bacteria
are actually plant pathogens or plant
killers.
So you've probably seen grass growing in
your backyard or whatever and it can be
all covered with frost,
but then you know the frost can
melt and it's still green. Yeah,
but if those bacteria present,
she says they'll spit out
their proteins onto the plant,
which generates these ice
crystals, the ice crystals,
then slice the plant open and
expose the inside of the plant.
At the bacteria say, mm, yummy.
He lunch and the eat the uh,
eat the inside of the plant. It's a good
strategy, but that's not the cool part.
Virginia says she has also found these
proteins in bacteria that don't kill
plants. So that made me
think, made her wonder why,
like why would they need to make ice?
And that's when it occurred to
her and a few other researchers.
Maybe it's about transportation.
Exactly what we're thinking about.
These bacteria are just sitting on these
plants and what happens is the wind
comes along,
blows up this little bacteria
into the upper atmosphere,
blows them literally up into the clouds.
[inaudible] not particularly cold
hardy. So now they have a situation,
they do not want to be
all the way up there.
They got to get back down to the earth.
And unless they hit your ride on those
horses that you keep talking about,
they're so light, they might not
come down to earth. So what they do,
she suspects is they use the plant trick.
They spit out these proteins
into the cold wet cloud,
which galvanizes the water
molecules around them to form
a snowflake around their body.
So now they've got this little hovercraft
that they can use to coast on down 15
meek ice.
They can get back down and they can get
back down in a different place and start
a new colony of bacteria somewhere
else. And so by this way,
they get dispersed around the
whole earth. Think about that.
The next time it's winter and it's snows.
Apparently if you melt each snowflake,
you will find a little bacterium
inside it. You're saying all of them,
all the stuff I eat, I haven't looked
at every single snowflake of course,
but it makes perfect sense, doesn't
it? But that's a myth. That's a very,
very cool idea. Yeah.
I suddenly like the bacteria Movio hell
of a lot better than the horse movie.
So at least I've, you know, and, and
it at least has a shot at being true.
Yeah. The horses.
So when we were reporting this story
and talking to Erin Pettit and Virginia
Walker and a bunch of other
scientists, when we asked them,
could an entire league have flash frozen
in an instant trapping all those horses
uniformly? The answer that we got
was no. Did you hear her? No. There.
Did you hear the sound of it?
Let me ask it to a different way.
When you say absolutely not,
just to kind of a gentle no,
I'd say that's an absolutely
not because as Aaron,
you told us when you're talking
about freezing an entire lake, oh,
you've got a lot of
problems to consider. First,
the process of freezing actually is a
source of heat itself because like when
water molecules form bonds to make ice,
that's a lot of activity and activity
produces energy and now that's going to
make things a little bit warmer.
Not to mention the fact that
horses are warm blooded animals,
so they also would slow down
the process of freezing. Right.
Also the water would never have been
pure enough to super cool in the first
place because there's,
there's too many things in the lake that
would provide that initial nucleation,
plants, organisms, dirt. Dammit.
Did somebody actually see this?
What is the actual evidence that um, no,
nobody saw
any of this as it actually happened
when we told Walter merge with the
scientists, told us in typical a
multi merge fashion, he was icy,
calm,
and you reminded us that he never told
us it was true that mallow parte often
mixed fact and fiction and that the real
reason he was attracted to this story
was because it offered a metaphor for
cosmology right at the beginning of the
universe.
Really. I mean, I feel,
excuse me if a small bit of skepticism
do things. It's true for the universe.
Metaphor, metaphor, the metaphor even.
So what does he mean? What do you mean?
Here's what he means. And if you're
a physicist listening right now,
just turn off the radio.
We're just talking among ourselves here,
right? So you can think of
it in one of two ways, right?
The first is that idea of super cooling
that we saw at Rockefeller where under
the right circumstances, water can
cool down way below its freezing point,
not freeze, and then all of a sudden,
oh
[inaudible]
and he can certainly do that, which we
saw at Rockefeller in the test tube. Now,
according to Jan 11 professor of
physics and astronomy, Foreign College,
Columbia University, the
metaphor holds because that flash
freezing phenomenon actually
happened repeatedly.
She says in the moments
after the Big Bang, yes,
Super Cooling is definitely something
that happens in the early universe.
She says, right when the universe
got its start, he was still small,
like the size of a grapefruit
inside that grapefruit.
It was extremely hot back then. It was
probably a million, trillion, trillion,
trillion times hotter, million,
trillion, trillion, trillion,
10 to the 32 times hotter. But as a
little grapefruit began to expand,
the temperature started to drop and it
dropped and dropped to a point where the
universe should freeze, so
to speak, but it didn't,
and it's waiting. It's waiting to freeze
and you're like, what's happening?
Why aren't you freezing? Then
suddenly, yeah. Oh, there it goes.
Phase change the, go ahead. Okay. I
don't know exactly what you're saying.
We keep going. All I'm saying is
there's a lot of face changes.
Some of them were super cool.
Don't worry about it. Okay.
There's another parallel, which I think
is actually even more interesting, um,
has to do with those seeds
we talked about. So if you
go back to the grapefruit,
okay,
inside, it's very, very hot.
You've got this wash of energy
and this energy is uniform, right?
It's all [inaudible] the
same thing spread evenly,
everywhere, the same.
But then as things cool,
you begin to get these tiny fluctuations,
little variations in temperature
and density [inaudible]
a little bit hotter and
denser in one point than another.
We're talking about clumps,
like maybe over here is a
little bit more mattered, right?
He'd been over there
and these are RC. I see.
I don't think that
you're describing seeds.
Like I understand seed seeds are little
things, things that attract other stuff.
No, no.
But these behave just like seeds because
as the universe cools down and expands
and begins to add all these new forces
and all these new particles, gravity,
electrons, photons, atoms,
those little bits of variation
from the beginning are still there.
And now they're growing bigger
because now we have gravity, right?
So little concentrations of stuff are
now attracting more stuff and then more
stuff and then more stuff.
And as the universe expands,
they expand into ultimately those
little blips have become these massive
objects.
It's amazingly the largest structures
that we know about in the universe have
their seeds in these tiny fluctuations.
Does that mean when you yeah,
go on a,
on a star wars kind of voyage.
So you're in your spaceship and you're
going at some incredibly high speeds.
You're rushing through the universe
and you see huge clouds of gas with
nurseries for stars and you leave them
and you go to a galaxy and then another
galaxy [inaudible] galaxy over
here and galaxy over there.
And collectively here you're saying
that these massive structures,
walls of galaxies, neighborhoods of stars,
that's gonna are reflections of very early
moment when something went
in the initial broil of stuff like this.
Some beautiful structures that you're
describing are like the snowflakes around
the little bit of dust.
What does that mean?
That the empty spaces that we see when
we gaze at the current universe are
actually filled with something that hasn't
cooled yet or that his quote or isn't
visible to us or is working
under different rules? I
can hijack your question.
I can say we might not have seen
the last of the phase transitions.
Our Universe is absolutely continuing
to cool. Is it really? Yeah,
it's cooling very cold
right now. We have this, uh,
dark energy driving the universe to expand
at an ever accelerated rate and it's
conceivable that in the future that
energy will endorse some phase transition
and it will go away or,
or decay to something else
in this new state of matter.
It might do something different
to the evolution of universe.
So we might have a phase
transition in our future.
[inaudible] [inaudible]
suddenly they get a little
[inaudible].